hey everybody and welcome to a powerful
wild ride with stevo this one is just
revealing and intimate we got a
wrestling legend peeling back the
curtain letting us know what really goes
on and opening up a whole lot so let's
get into it
ladies and gentlemen drew mcintyre yeah
dude
and i'm led so are you
wasn't wasn't gonna say it's over on the
air but i love the t-shirt you got there
are the insane clown posse
was that the same clown foxy
oh no way i always wanted to wrestle at
the gathering of the juggalos but i
never got the chance oh my god dude
we just got back from the gathering of
the juggalos and there was
the
craziest awesomest experience ever yeah
it's probably the coolest thing i've
done in the last like you know five
years for
i always sure how cool it was and the
three years i was gone from wwe that was
one of the places i wanted to work and
timing wise it just never worked out and
obviously you know getting permission
from wwe to work the gathering of the
juggles is a little difficult right they
did have a wrestling ring there on stage
really people wrestling
yeah they do i don't know what they did
in there but they certainly had a
wrestling ring oh yeah they definitely
have wrestling and all sorts of stuff
going on
that's right shaggy was telling me that
uh their whole deal started with
wrestling
um
well okay so this is my co-host scott
randolph assuming that you guys have you
spoke a little bit all right and i'm up
at the front of the van we've got the
gorgeous paul briskey hi drew nice to
meet you what's up gorgeous folk
it's great to see you again uh so you
didn't have to travel far to go to that
uh shack bowl where we met in tampa
because you live in tampa
i did at the time i guess it was a very
a close drive for me but now if i was to
drive it would take about 12 hours i
just moved to nashville tennessee about
four weeks ago so this is my new digs
i'm coming from right now nice man cool
what was the reason for the move just a
new beginning yeah that'll be way to
change i've lived in florida the whole
time i've been in america it's almost 13
years now my wife has work opportunities
here she works in the medical field she
has family close by we got friends um
around this area and it reminds me of
scotland you know a lot of hills a lot
of greenery and we've got seasons here
which i kind of miss
all right yeah it's lush you guys are
getting pretty rained out right now
though right in nashville
i mean not
no it's actually really sunny i did hear
about the the floods unfortunately
they're about an hour and a half from
where i'm at and mount juliet area but
yeah we've been very fortunate just how
sunny it is here
it's good yeah dude so you're the wwe
champion
and former wwe champion unfortunately
when i met you at the shack bowl i was
currently a champion at the time but i'm
fighting to get that thing back right
now good man good now
i see it sounded counterintuitive to me
it's a wwe champion is there not like
champions of each different weight
division
uh well the wwe championship is
considered the main title in wwe it's
the wwe heavyweight championship but we
also have another title which is equal
in value and the wwe championships on
our flagship show monday night raw on
usa
and fridays on fox we have wwe smackdown
which has the universal championship
both equal in value and then we have
other titles of the intercontinental
championship united states championship
and the tag team championship which is
obviously two people at the same time
that our champion but the wwe title
that's a big one i've had it twice i
don't want it back yeah how does your
life change when you have that that
strap
is life getting different for you a lot
more responsibility yeah the
responsibility level goes up i love that
you know this is all i ever wanted to do
i've been wrestling for 21 years i
started i was 15 years old when i
finally won the wwe title
timing-wise it wasn't ideal so working
my whole life to get my wwe title match
i won an event called the royal rumble
in 2020 40 000 people went crazy in
houston texas this royal rumble event i
won i won my first heavyweight title
match i could select the champion i
wanted to fight i chose brock lesnar
he's the guy i wanted to fight i'm crazy
enough to fight brock lesnar we're going
to face each other wrestlemania that
year 90 000 people my american hometown
at the time tampa florida my wife was
going to be there my family from
scotland were going to be there
then the pandemic hit so
unfortunately i won the wwe championship
in front of nobody at wrestlemania not
how i dreamed of it as a kid but at the
time you know every other sport shut
down every other entertainment company
shut down wwe was only original content
the world we're bringing everyone
wrestlemania at the height and the
pandemic my match was last let's get a
feel good story with all the ups and
downs i've been through in my life and
career it was kind of happy ending so i
was very proud to be champion during the
period when we had no fans i lost the
title during that period i want it back
when we had virtual fans and i lost it
before we got the fans back live so now
we have our live fans back i've been
champion for over 300 days and i've
never been championing my live fans
which drives me insane
wow
so
is that the only time that you wrestled
with brock lesnar
uh yes we had a program from january
when i won the royal rumble to
wrestlemania which is
like a three four month period where
we're interacting with each other and i
was getting to drop him a few times
which doesn't happen very often not many
men on this earth drop brock lesnar but
i was able to drop him multiple times it
really helped elevate my character
elevate my stock and when i beat him i
beat him in five minutes at wrestlemania
yeah let's be honest you whooped his ass
i absolutely looked his ass
five minutes beaten brought lesnar but
brock lesnar really cemented your
american tower as a top player in wwe
and really you know put me on top of the
mountain and allowed me to leave the
charge for wwe in one of the strangest
times in our history at the height of
the pandemic yeah is it scarier
to face brock lesnar given
his uh transition to mma in becoming a
ufc guy
i'm sure it was scary to face him at any
time
in your life this is a guy that's just a
freak of nature an incredible athlete
ncaa champion multiple times for
heavyweight wrestling get into wwe
incredibly young won the world title
youngest world champion in history 23
years old dominated wwe decided to
travel
and you know how hard we can be on the
body and the mind was too hard for him
so he quit and then became ufc champion
instead because he thought that was a
little easier then returned to wwe with
a reduced schedule so i feel very
fortunate that i was able to face and
defeat somebody of that caliber yeah
dude unbelievable
now you you mentioned your ups and downs
in uh in your career and we were talking
before
before you know starting the podcast
with you about how
arguably the the biggest
down of your career
seems to be
like really deliberately part of a wwe
storyline like where you're in the
middle of a match and they say
that's it you're fired right like it
felt like that had to be
you know part of the this manufactured
you know wwe story
but then
you're on the independent circuit and
it's like
even we were trying to make sense of
that you know like uh
i mean i guess you don't want to peel
back the curtain too much with wwe but
it's obviously something that was
incredibly real because here you go off
into all these other organizations
but uh i mean it's just crazy but then
of course you come back and you become
champion
like uh did it what was that like
i'm very open about everything you can
ask whatever you want i'm not afraid to
talk about anything um i think what you
might have watched or referring to is i
got fired quotation marks and a
storyline on television a few years ago
that was just part of the story like my
character was on a downward spiral i got
fired and then i got rehired and i
continued on for a couple of years and
then in 2014 i got fired for real that
was the story
he said you're fired it's two different
things one was part of the show the
other was you're fired from your dream
job and the truth is that um
sometimes the truth can be hard to admit
but since drew mcintyre is about to open
up so much so will i
i am self-conscious of my gray hair okay
that's why when i get my hair cut it's
got to be so close to the skin that's
why it's so important to me to manscape
okay because my chest hair is gray dude
and i just feel like i look better and
have more confidence if i'm well groomed
right and that's why i use manscaped
dude their lawnmower 4.0 is the best
men's grooming device out there plus
their weed whacker keeps all the hair
out of my nostrils man it's a bad look
if you got hair coming out of your
nostrils and i know that you need to try
this so that's why if you go to
manscaped.com
stevo you get 20 off your order plus
free shipping don't look like a slob
with disgusting hair okay groom yourself
with manscaped and get this killer deal
by going to manscaped.como
for 20 off your order and free shipping
now let's get into that truth
you know i'd lost perspective at that
point when i was a kid i'd always
dreamed of being a wwe in here scotland
wouldn't have done anything to get there
did do anything together work mars off
from 15 years old to 21 get my education
at the same time got my degree from
university criminology miraculously got
signed as a first ever scotsman the wwe
would have been happy to be the water
boy at that point and they got to the
point throughout my career after 23
years old been named the chosen one by
vincent mann on television the future of
the company getting these huge
opportunities screwing them up going and
not just a downward spiral on television
but in my personal life a lot was going
on my mother got sick outside of the
ring away in scotland with cancer she
inevitably passed and outside the ring i
was a train wreck i was going out
drinking all the time partying all the
time arguing with people at work annoyed
with my position and quite frankly i had
to get fired to get a wake-up call and
the day i got fired is the day i sat
looked myself in the mirror and said
this is our new buddy
and you know you're going through a lot
you probably should have faced but at
the same time you lost perspective from
that day forward i promised myself i
would work as hard as i possibly could
in every area of my game i'd be
accountable for the first time to the
person in the mirror and i would work my
way back to wwe one way or another and
also i gotta take a second to thank the
wife because as much as i was gonna work
hard in the wrestling aspect that's all
i knew as a person i was so immature you
know i was a boy when i got fired she
helped me grow so much as a man
throughout that time period i traveled
the world i was the busiest wrestler in
the world to help grow multiple
companies all across the globe and it
felt really good that in wwe the name
sells the brand you see wwe unless it's
john cena of the rock you're gonna go
see wwe that my real name drew galloway
was helping multiple companies across
the world grow like in scotland we went
from fifteen hundred people to two
thousand people to four thousand people
to over seven thousand people night a
big effect on that that was a great
period for me to grow as a wrestler but
grow as a man and three years later i
had a phone call with triple h basically
it was time to come home i returned to
wwe and thankfully it was time for me to
become the top guy become wwe champion
so it's been a fun old ride the past 13
years i've been in america that's for
sure
man i i gotta say that
it's impressive
like
to hear you
talk about your accountability and you
know like hey that was on me i saw that
and and some stuff the some videos i
watched about you and uh universally you
get a lot of credit and a lot of respect
for for owning up you know for from
manning up and and taking accountability
and that's just that's awesome man i
love to hear it
i can think of one guy who i wish would
adopt that approach to life
and uh yeah dude so um
congrats on all that man and and the
story of growing up and
you know being accountable again man i
love that
i documented all right here
we've got a book called a chosen destiny
the dream mcintyre story crazy so you're
holding a hardcover version of it which
presumably means it's new
uh yeah it came out um a few months ago
and it's basically the story um in depth
that i just told you know i never
thought to myself like during a
worldwide pandemic you know what the
world needs right now is that 35 year
old wrestler from wwe's story like an
outside company came to wwe talked about
how open and honest i am about my story
and all my downfalls and how many times
i've had to fight back my resilience etc
and basically said we think it could
inspire some people would really be
willing to put it down in a book so i
spoke to the wife about it we decided
yes but i want to be as open as possible
we'll make wrestling the foundation of
the book the normal wrestler will
simplify the industry explain how it
works but that's not what it's all about
it's about showing people no matter how
dark times can get and i've been through
some dark-ass times there's always a
light at the end of the tunnel you just
got to keep believing got to keep
fighting and surround yourself with
positive people and if my book can
inspire just one person to chase their
dreams or get out of those dark times
that's what it's all about i love it man
i i don't think it's fair to say there's
always a light at the end of the tunnel
but i think it is fair to say there
always can be a light at the end of the
tunnel if you choose to pursue one a lot
of people that we talked about earlier
is that like looking in the mirror and
that's right accountability and being
honest with yourself part because i was
not honest for a long time there was
times where i would even look in the
mirror most days because i didn't like
what i saw but eventually if you get to
that point you can look yourself in the
mirror be honest say today i'm going to
give it my best even if it's just a
little progression every single day and
by the end of the day if you can look
back in that mirror and say i gave it
the best i had today i tried to be
positive because negativity can only
bring negativity and you can't lie to
yourself in the mirror and you keep that
up every day you'll keep getting better
keep getting better i know because i've
done it twice over
yeah dude that's awesome man uh and it
sounds
dude also thank you for for your candor
you know to
to be
transparent like that's what we love
that on here and i know that everybody
watching and listening loves it too
and that lends credibility to the book
you know you said that you're out there
drinking or drinking like crazy you got
all the crazy
you know like juicy stuff for the book
and and with the you know the happy
ending about you know growing up and
life becoming good i think that sounds
like a book that's well worth purchasing
so
what's your preferred way for people to
buy the book uh i've been very lucky
that it's literally everywhere i think
it's on amazon and walmart target like i
walk into the store and see my see my
stupid face on the shelf like i've been
very fortunate fortunately it's
everywhere and that's the thing about
being like honest and open i always am
at all times and it's funny that when i
finally connected with our wwe audience
was when i started just being myself
i've been wrestling 20 years and within
wwe was always a bad guy i'm a foreign
guy i'm 6'5 217 hairy and scottish got
to be a bad guy i talked about eating
carcasses i was angry all the time no
one can relate to a giant hairy angry
scotsman except the one guy in scotland
who's giant hairy and angry i get that
guy yeah finally i was allowed to be
myself i talked the way i'm talking
right now in the microphone maybe
annunciated a little more told some of
my jokes which are dad jokes i'm not
really funny i'm sarcastic in real life
i'm not afraid afraid to fall flat in my
face and i've obviously you know got the
story of fighting and overcoming a lot
we started telling that in television i
started being the real me and the crowd
started responding so positively and it
was all organic it was all being myself
but the volume turned up a little bit
and i couldn't believe that i was like
all i had to do was be myself and i'd
finally make that connection with the
audience and since then you know i
always try never put my situation in a
situation where i have to lie i'd rather
say nothing than ever
for sure man i feel like people that
grow up in scotland are automatically
just tougher than american people you
know like i i imagine you growing up in
scotland just getting in a lot of fights
or you know being the big guy i feel
like people always want to challenge you
is that true growing up in grade school
in high school
yeah a few times i wasn't so bad because
in america i'm a big guy but in scotland
i'm a monster i was always headed
shoulders above everybody and i used to
hate it when i was a kid i was like oh
my goodness i'm afraid because i was
literally when i say head and shoulders
i mean head and shoulders above everyone
i saw it as a negative thing until i got
to like 10 11 wanted to be arrested i
realized they were huge went oh wait
this is actually a good thing but there
were a few times where i was at the bus
stop with friends when i went to like
the secondary school we call it age 11
and people like oh there's drew the
wrestler and the expression in scotland
someone wants to start a fight for some
reason is what you're looking at clearly
you're looking at them i don't know why
people say in scotland but they do and
then my response was clearly i'm looking
at you so this one guy and his five
friends or whatever like step forward
and one of them went wait this was my
nickname when i was a kid that's through
the wrestlers i don't care who he is
this is before i started wrestling the
guy grabbed me in a headlock instead of
throwing a punch i never know why he
grabbed me a headlock but i stood up
with him and threw him against the bus
stop and he hit it like a movie
splattered in his face these kids were a
bit older than us that day forward
nobody messed with me and i was through
the wrestle officially wow i love it
don't mess with drew you said you've
been wrestling for 21 years
yeah since i was 15 i'm 36 now just
turned okay i'm dying to know like
uh in any of your 21 years of wrestling
did you ever like secretly tape a razor
blade under a wristband or a headband so
that you could like take a shot and then
be a bloody mess and make it like a more
exciting match
uh not in wwe and i've only done it a
couple of times
that's the thing he's done it yes we
stopped yeah we stopped using blood in
wwe you know a long time ago you know we
can tell our stories without you know
getting that graphic um but i'd be lying
if i said that three-year period i was
gone in wwe i worked for a lot of over
18's companies including the one i
mentioned where we grew the crowd from
1500 to over 7 000 people and i got in
some significant deep feuds with some of
my childhood friends we made things so
personal like i involved my dad in a
storyline i involved multiple people
throughout my childhood in a story like
we made it so real that the person i was
feeling with my friend who wrestles as
jack jester like started not talking to
me he was so offended all the time he
literally started hating me that's how i
really got and during her big match i
might have used something to help me get
some blood
that's fantastic how'd you know about
that well i mean i i'm a big-time blood
letter dude you know
and i i was actually at the gathering of
the juggalos i showed up and and i said
i
i promise you guys by the end of the
night i will be covered in my own blood
and uh you know my trick is to break a
light bulb over my head and then with a
shard of broken glass like you know cut
my tongue
because it's it bleeds a ton
and the tongue is the fastest healing
part of your body so it's like you can
bleed all over yourself and then like
five minutes later you're you're back to
normal and maybe some of the older
wrestlers should have done that you know
back in the day it was more prevalent
the threats was cutting themselves if
you ever had the chance to meet like a
dusty roads for example their foreheads
are so marked in the years of cutting
themselves to get the blood effect they
probably should have cut their tongue
and just rubbed it in their heads right
probably yeah you know what they did i'm
dead like every once in a while i i
break out a crazy story that i've never
told
when i was uh
was maybe like six seven eight i was
very very young for some reason
i i was in my parents bathroom just
messing around being mischievous and i
and i took their their toothpaste and
squeezed it onto the counter
and i thought why did i do that dude
that was dumb you know like i i gotta
clean this up so the first thing i saw
to grab to clean it up was a a
disposable razor by the thing and so i
took the razor and like tried to scrape
off the toothpaste but then i look at it
oh no well now i've gotten this
toothpaste on this razor now this is
even worse so i take the razor and i
[ __ ] licked it to try to
to lick off the i'm trying to lick the
toothpaste off the razor and i'm like
now my tongue's bleeding like crazy
everywhere i'm like no now i'm really
going to be in trouble
and and i i went and
i grabbed a bunch of toilet paper and
put it on my tongue and i would squeeze
it really hard and like it stopped
bleeding really fast and then uh and
then i flushed the toilet paper and i
just used toilet paper to clean up the
counter and like
and rinsed off nobody was ever the wiser
it was i'm the only one that grew up
being the only one who knew that ever
happened
you wait during the other time last year
i mean yeah
43.
yeah it's interesting it was my own
little secret and i grew up with it and
then and then when they taught me how to
chew and swallow glass uh you know as a
clown not that they not the clowns do
that but a clown taught me that i
thought oh when i break the light bulb i
cut my tongue you've never told anybody
that before i don't if i have i have not
like i don't know i don't think so what
else you got going on yeah i thought i
told you some of these stories yeah
like i mean maybe maybe
maybe i did i don't know i know it's in
my book
i love how like every solution just made
it worse and worse you're like then my
parents were coming home i didn't want
that to happen so i burned the house
down there's nothing to go to they'll
never catch me
yeah that'd be a funny cartoon if any
guest is listening they can draw a
cartoon to that story they're like
amelia bedelia
right but in any case i was i get in
trouble for telling stories about myself
when i know that was a good one that was
a good one
quick question on your shirt is that the
predator what had when he was dying oh
what happened there it's all right you
guys still here oh wait yeah he [ __ ]
us drew can you hear us
oh
sorry i knocked the sound board off that
that t-shirt that you got is that the
predator that's what was seen when he
was like deprogramming at the very end
and it absolutely was good eye yeah
okay so predator shirt right before he
tries to blow up arnold yeah exactly
in relation to that i have a question
have you gotten into much acting i
looked at your imdb i didn't see much
and it surprised me because you've got
this great character this presence have
you tried to get acting roles and do you
have interest in that
well thank you um it's weird i've been
getting this question a lot over the
past six months and like today i've had
it that's the third time i've been asked
it today and i remember asking my wife
like you know why do people keep asking
me this is like joe you look like you've
fallen out of game of thrones or
braveheart
yeah you're like 300.
so yeah i mean it's something that if
right now i'm so
involved with wwe on screen and off
screen with a lot of projects the only
way i'd probably do it if it would help
boost my profile which in turn would
help wwe and draw new eyeballs to the
product but eventually one day you know
that's maybe something i'd look into i'm
sure everyone expect me to go into like
action movies or whatever i want to do
something sensitive show my range cry a
lot yeah that's where i'm gonna go down
actually i've got a pitch this is the
movie if someone makes this right now
i've pitched this a few times if
somebody wants to make this movie i'm
your guy
i get the sense that drew is very
passionate about this idea of his and
you know what i'm passionate about
my butthole because dude i was just on a
trip
and i wiped as well as i could but still
man i ended up with like a rash between
my butt cheeks dude i know you know what
i'm talking about and it never happens
when i'm at home because my toilet is
outfitted with tushy okay
hellotushy.com is where you get this
magical device
which when you get done taking a big
sloppy dump you just twist the dial and
blast
a refreshing
stream of water it's like it's like
pressure cleaning your butthole man
there is absolutely no reason why i
should be doing it for this long but i
enjoy it okay and it gets my butthole so
clean plus how much less toilet paper am
i using we're saving the world around
here folks i have to say this is my
favorite thing man and whenever i have
to poop and i'm not at home it's like a
real problem with me
ah dude i get done i use my tushy
and then like nothing on there isn't it
nice to wipe your butt and not see a big
mess on the toilet paper after you wipe
that's what this is about folks so go to
hellotushy
stevo get yourself one of these because
it's like you're going to feel how did i
ever live without it that's how i feel
hellotushy.como and that gets you 10 off
your order plus free shipping
i'll just tell you this is my favorite
product i've ever been introduced to by
this podcast so thank you
hellotushi.como
now let's hear that idea so now the
braveheart william wallace gets killed
just like he did in real life hung drawn
and quartered by the english his body
parts are scattered across the four
parts of the uk his head is putting
london bridge
so braveheart too zombies are still in
right now batista just for the new
zombie movie somebody gets his body
parts they put them back together he
returns a zombie wallace and wreaks
havoc in the english braveheart 2 the
rise of wallace i'll play zombie wallace
where does it require somebody to get as
far as wouldn't it be kind of funny if
like the the all the parts just started
making their way back together like oh
yeah
yeah like like like you see like the arm
like putting your the arm
itself over to the head the the eyes
open up on the on the spike on london
bridge like the head the eyes open up
and then
like you see the head wiggle a little
bit and the head just hops off i like it
dude run yourself in your head i saw it
in a series for a second but now i'm
seeing it like evil dead or something i
think we're onto something we're
brainstorming this spring part
we're workshopping this thing how often
do you wear a kilt
um these days a lot um i used to only
wear a kilt to weddings and the likes um
including my own wedding and my wife
made me promise you have to wear
underwear you and your groomsmen have to
wear underwear
for the wedding and i said i promise
what we're underwear for the wedding so
sure enough i wore underwear the second
said i do did her thing she went off
with the girls i got the guys together
let's get rid of these underwears chuck
them away and she never found out till
later that night we got rid of the
underwear because it's not official if
you're scottish if you're wearing
underpants unless you happen to be
working on live television because these
days on monday night raw i do come out
wearing the kill i come out with a giant
scottish claymore which is about a five
foot sword i shove it in the stage and
it sets off a pyrotechnic show so
unfortunately if i went through scottish
on monday night raw i'd probably get
kicked off the television so i have to
wear my gear underneath
nice remember in aberdeen we we got
fitted for kilts and you were doing
handstands in the in the dressing room
i don't i don't remember that but that
sounds funny remember when we dressed up
i remember yeah that was it was great
when we were in school yeah we were
trying to do handstands
you were at least the yeah yeah wow
that was a we had a great time in
scotland um so
i i saw this this footage and it was
super disturbing where
where it wasn't in wwe i think it was
was it maybe
wpcw
and uh yeah
and it was like an accident there was a
super like almost career-ending
career-ending injury where you got
spiked on the top of your head
and and
it was described that you that you
weren't you were feeling the
this sensation like leaving your arms
like you could see in the footage you
were wiggling your fingers thinking like
oh no i've just i've just done broke my
neck and become paralyzed
and you did it and you couldn't do
anything for two months
following that like what was that two
months like i mean the moment itself was
more terrifying than the two months um
but yeah i took a maneuver that i
shouldn't have agreed to take it was a
dangerous ddt and the ddt's removed jake
roberts popularized you take your
opponent head under the shoulder you
fall back they land on their head this
involved lifting your opponent in the
air and then dropping them into their
head and the guy giving it to me was
half my size and i knew mechanically it
wasn't safe i still agreed to take it
and essentially when i landed it was
like diving into a swimming pool with
your hands behind your back and kissed
your own chest that's how hard i landed
and beca because i kissed my own chest
my ear was against my chest and i heard
the bones cracking
so yeah i landed told him basically f
off get away from me i lay there like
lost the sensation my fingers for a
second they did kind of come back and i
was as you saw in the footage testing
you know my fingers and my boots i was
wiggling my toes too just to make sure i
had the feeling there i was very scared
to be honest i refused to help out the
ring i got myself up and walked myself
to the back knowing i'd done serious
damage and told them they call me an
ambulance right now because it was in
the uk and the nhs is not always the
best with sending an ambulance even
though it's free healthcare it took four
hours for the ambulance to get there and
i was sitting swinging my head around
doing neck stretches and things i should
not have been doing
i got taken to the hospital finally
which i refused to get stretchered out
because we have to stretch you out
there's fans out back i didn't want
anybody to know so i told the ambulance
meet me around the corner which they
shouldn't have been there but they did
for me because because i refused to go
out all the fans were waiting out there
i didn't want any pictures getting
stretchered out so i walked out i sang
some autographs took some
pictures walked around the corner
creeped into the ambulance and then they
strapped me to the gurney with a lock
your neck in place and then i just i lay
on that thing for hours like constant
panic attacks thankfully i had my phone
just playing on my phone texting my wife
her telling me it's gonna be okay got an
x-ray they told me there's something
going on but we need an mri it's gonna
take a couple of weeks i told them i
don't have that i flew back to america
the next day
uh with this injury head swinging around
while i was sleeping got that mri and
sure enough i'd broken a non-displaced
black fracture thankfully my t3 and t4
in my neck and the doctor looked at the
footage and said like you don't know how
lucky you are like the bones are broken
but being non-displaced they'll heal
themselves you just have to wear a body
brace from the neck down to your torso
basically i basically stayed indoors
that entire time i didn't want anyone to
see it take any pictures of me i did
some shows but i took off the neck brace
before i only talked on the show i
walked back from the rain got backstage
put the neck brace on left of the show
in the car with my wife kept it a secret
and it wasn't until a few years later
when i finally started talking about it
publicly and the book extensively but it
was terrifying and i was in hiding for
that two months so nobody knew man so
that sounds like it's absolutely your
worst wrestling injury that you ever had
yeah the most scary by far the worst one
that took me out for the longest was my
bicep
scar but i tore it like off the bone the
surgeon did a great job and it popped
off one time during a match
and uh it took about four months to
recover the neck took two months for the
bone to heal but it could have been
disastrous and sounds worse when you
tell somebody i broke an egg yeah i mean
it was better it was okay
what would you mean it's a broken neck i
was like okay
i got very lucky it just doesn't sound
great
took four months did you break both your
biceps because they look really swollen
right now
oh yeah this one's really broken
yeah you didn't just break your neck you
you fractured two separate vertebrae in
your neck your cervical spine
yeah yeah it was scary to look at the
mri the doctor to explain what's going
on as well as to show me you know that's
a herniation herniation that's what's
going on there those are not currently
affecting you but one day they will and
oh that's wonderful and at the time i
was about 32 years old
it's not what you want to hear since
then i've made a lot of changes in my
life aside you know the obvious changes
and cutting out the partying etc you
know i've started eating healthier
hydrating i've got my giant gallon of
water here i stretch all the time i'm
all about staying healthy these days i
need to hydrate man i forgot can you
grab me a liquid death dude you want me
to grab you a liquid i just don't want
to get up and move so drew how um
yeah liquid death is
speaking of hydrate this epic water we
drink so how apprehensive were you after
those two months getting back in the
ring doing certain moves again were you
was there like
a kind of still a shaky period for a
while or were you right back on the
horse full
blast yeah i was a little worried but i
knew i had to go in a hundred percent i
could never wrestling if you hold back
the slightest you can hurt yourself or
hurt your opponent there's a lot of
trust replacing each other not to hurt
each other so i knew i had to be ready
mentally but the thing is because it was
such a real thing and i finally kind of
revealed to the crowd what was going on
and i decided because it was real i went
involved in a storyline so that show i
talked about in scotland were over 7 000
people were going to have at the biggest
show an independent wrestling ever the
biggest show in uk wrestling outside wwe
in 30 years and i wanted to be on it so
i did the speech i explained what
happened i explained the injury
that this crowd are over 18's they're
very intelligent how wrestling works and
how that particular company insane
championship wrestling works in glasgow
so they didn't buy it at the start when
i started talking about my life my
career my family the sacrifices i've
made to move to america for so many
years my dad was in the crowd crying the
person i was feuding with at the time
who won the company came out to make it
look as real as possible and somebody
shouted something he threw them out the
building was ready to fight them because
we're trying to make it such a serious
moment i got the crowd crying by the end
of it like i can't participate in this
big show tomorrow and i'm going to be
there and i just i'm absolutely
devastated so i finally got them after
my oscar winning 10 minute speech but
then i just turned and punched the guy i
was feeding with in the face right at
the peak of it when everyone was in
tears and he gave me a big hug and i
just dropped him out of nowhere and then
i screamed his name's mark dallas i
screamed f you dallas i'm drew ethan
galloway nothing's gonna stop me
fighting tomorrow so sure enough
everybody hated me and we had to sneak
me out the back door because people were
ready to stab me basically they were so
irate but that's the fun thing about our
industry when you can get people and
really get them especially those that
think they know the industry is such a
cool feeling but that was like if anyone
looks it up online that was my oscar
performance right there that's great man
i mean
with the the neck stuff and and just the
the degenerative like
the quality of wrestling uh have you
thought about trying stem cell therapy
yeah i mean a lot of the guys have done
it
they swear by it and it's something i've
spoke to the misses about and
you know i reckon in the future i'll
definitely go down that route and when
she works in the medical field there is
evidence but not enough evidence um in
her opinion but a lot of the guys swear
by it so i'm just gonna keep doing my
research
good good yeah i got uh
i got an offer to go do stem cell
therapy
in colombia where that where the the
procedures that they do are just not
approved in america
like are arguably because
like to approve those procedures in
america would put a ding in the
pharmaceutical injury or the
industry and you know whatever but it's
interesting because i have degenerative
disc disease in my neck and uh it sort
of preemptively wanted to get down there
before it becomes painful and
debilitating so i feel like it made a
difference i mean it it's only been a
couple months and and nothing's supposed
to be any different for like three to
six months
and the real change is supposed to come
in about a year
um and with that said
also uh
i'm not i hadn't reached a point where
it was painful or debilitating yet so
you know
it's it's gonna be tough to say oh the
pain went away or anything like that you
know like
so it's a pain as long as the pain never
comes like it's worth it i would love
that yeah i would love that so
i i had a pretty legendary match in the
wwe on monday night raw
uh with my my jackass partner uh chris
pontius and and we
we both took on umaga and it was pretty
legendary i actually got beaten into a
blackout because i did not know
that the match isn't over until you stop
moving
you know and like and i just like
typically react when something happens
to me like if i take a blow like i i
have a reaction and so
i had a reaction i'm rolling around like
oh yeah and like this was taken as a
sign of disrespect to umaga like don't
don't roll around don't be like you know
don't be reacting like
you want to keep moving around i'm going
to keep hitting you
and uh and that's
laughing too and i was laughing too
because like you know it's just part of
my natural reaction so i mean it turned
out that he just kept beating me until
like i
like
fully blacked out like i
i swear i do not ever remember
leaving the ring and it got dark enough
that they cut the commercial so they
never showed me to leave the ring it's
just a mystery to me whatever happened
the next thing i remember i was in like
the uh the sound booth whatever like uh
you know the control room
and uh you know and then that was just i
don't know what happened but
um
i i think that i didn't the reason i
told this story and definitely told that
one before
is because uh
there's been a bunch of like kind of
like celebrities on like the promotional
circuit and they arranged to go promote
their movie or whatever it is by going
into the ring and having to some extent
like uh participation in some kind of a
match or something
and uh i think that typically the the
wwe wrestlers will go a little easy on
on the celebrities when they're in the
ring but that certainly was not the case
for me and my buddy which is
understandable
i'm just kind of curious like if like if
you've dealt with any like big
celebrities in the ring
um i've not personally been involved in
any angles as we call them with any
celebrities in the ring just yet i do
remember that incident i got the feeling
it was the laughing thing even if it was
like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like you
didn't mean to like uh like i know if i
was in that position and uh like the
character he was playing was you know
like such a big angry you know tough bad
guy from samoa like if he saw that i can
i'm sure i know what he was thinking
when he did it and sorry you have to go
through that
and enhance this character massively and
at the same time probably enhance
yourself
one of the best things that ever
happened to me
i remember one time backstage um like
sean michaels and uh triple h were
working with uh seth green
and for an angle they were going to do
in the television show one time with
they had a group called the generation x
and seth was going to be involved with
it and uh they called me into the ring
like i was stuck in a new at the time
like 23 i believe and they're like okay
a set needs to work on like a punch or
whatever like how he's going to throw
this punch so i got in the ring and you
know he's a little bit shorter um so you
know throw it up and aim for basically
here and i told him just hit me you know
i don't mind you know taking a hit as
long as you don't hit me in the nose or
the eyes etc just just hit me make it
look good they proceeded to just punch
me straight in the throat
so i would rather that was over on tv
but it hurts so much but yeah that's the
closest interaction i've had with any
physicality funny that was probably just
as high as he could reach was the throat
yeah i'm trying to be nice lovely guy
very talented yeah he's a little shorter
wow and you're a giant i even like you
standing next to brock lesnar i was
shocked you're almost like you're a half
a head taller than brock lesnar
yeah yeah i'm a little taller
and that's interesting when i was gone
from wwe and i was working on myself and
thinking of the areas i need to improve
like my body was one of them and i
actually used brock as like an image in
my head it was the biggest match in wwe
brock he's the biggest drawing card in
the world in wwe right now i have to
look believable in front of them there's
nothing worse when somebody stands in
front of somebody wwe that's laughable
that guy couldn't fight that guy even
within the confines of professional
wrestling so i built my body up with the
mindset of i want to go face to face
with brock one day and people go oh i
believe he can fight him and i continue
to build my body i'll build my body up
with the eating correctly and training
etc until the moment i finally did that
and i saw the picture and i saw the
footage back and i was like wow it's
crazy if you just imagine something hard
enough work hard enough and he was
literally the image i had in my head as
i was building my body up and then it
happened in real life and i literally
was looking down at him he's got me by
about 20 pounds 25 pounds but just the
height makes such a difference as well
as you know we're not that far off
mass-wise so that was a special moment
for myself
wow so he's got to cut a lot of weight
to make that ufc 265
yeah yeah he does for sure i did for
sure he's such a big big guy it's hard
to imagine that brock lesnar uh hasn't
gotten
that big with the help of a little bit
of steroids or something
i mean
not wwe i can say that much like
thankfully so they're pretty strict
oh unbelievably and it's great you know
since i signed with wwe you know the
wellness policy we call it got
incredibly straight we test for every
performing expansion drug uh imaginable
uh when it comes to our health health is
paranoid we get tested for our heart
cardiovascular once a year if you get a
head injury you have to pass an impact
test like the nfl or any other sport
before you're allowed back in the ring
even our former superstars we have drug
rehab programs if they get involved with
drugs and want help wwe you pay for it
you know health is number one these days
thank goodness
fantastic well i take that back entirely
so but brock lesnar is naturally that
huge
100 like we get tested all the time i
actually just get tested this past
monday and it's always random multiple
times a year that's great man
go wwe because i know that that all
right i think that wasn't always the
case right i mean
yeah
i think a lot of people have been made i
can't say 100 percent but you know yeah
i
like everybody's 100
i love to hear that man i really love to
hear that they're
taking care of their their their people
how about every area as well even like
mental health is something thank
goodness it's getting focused on so much
these days you know we have like an
outside party it's not directly involved
with wwe you can get help through wwe
and speak to outside party if you're
having any mental health problems and
it's thanks for getting top of that
these days you know that's something
that's important to myself we actually
just lost something wrestling today and
um
it really sucks and i've lost a friend
within wrestling a couple of years ago
when somebody i came up with the
happiest person in the world was doing
great in wrestling it wasn't his
full-time job he worked also at the same
time was so happy he called me to tell
me that one of my other friends was
struggling and then he just took his
life just so unexpected and shocked
everybody we never saw it coming and i'm
always you know adamant to tell people
it's okay to not be okay especially if
you're guys having a big macho anymore
it's like tougher to tell somebody i'm
struggling right now and reach out and
get help
yeah dude
is the problem in the in wrestling like
with is it is a lot of prescription
pills or is it drinking or is it both or
does one perceive the other i mean i i
have to imagine that a lot of guys are
in a lot of pain
and they just kind of yeah i mean i
think in the past and that seemed to be
the case like i say these days since the
wellness policy came to effect it's been
eradicated but if anybody has those
issues or have developed those issues
since the left wwe you know just reach
out to wwe and they'll look after you
and they'll get you the help you need
i never knew that about the wwe i'm glad
to know that
that's that's good the uh so so when
you're on the road during monday night
raw i mean i guess like in normal times
every monday you're in a different city
right like uh that's just kind of how it
works and and as i understood it it was
um like the wrestlers were responsible
for getting themselves from city to city
and they had to pay for that you have to
pay for your own travel your own hotels
is it still that way
uh when it comes to the cars hotels yes
and we handle our own cars hotels
everybody pays for the flights then you
handle your own food which i prefer i do
like ready-made meals meal prep that i
bring on the road with me so i can stick
to my diet at home and on the road i
love being on the road i missed it so
much for the two years that i was at
home it was awesome in the sense that i
got to spend a lot of time with my wife
and i know a lot of couples were having
troubles and divorcing during that time
spent so much time together we actually
grew closer which is nice we're gonna
make it seems my two cats my two cats
were happy that i was home but and i'm a
road warrior i miss been on the road i'm
excited to be back in front of the live
fans and making the towns and those
drives are so much fun for me and just
chatting with the guys catching up with
the guys and having that guy time that i
didn't have for the past year and a half
two years
dude that's epic okay let's talk about
this criminology business man like uh i
just about watch nothing except for true
crime
like programming that's all i'm
interested in that's all that's all i'm
interested in
my wife is always watching like um
what's that one where the females always
kill their husbands
i'm always walking and she's watching
that like why are you always watching
this
[Music]
and why are you taking notes
yeah um so like
on uh i've seen on on youtube there's a
channel called jcs criminal psychology
if you're not aware if you're not aware
of it dude
say goodbye then the next 30 hours of
your life
tonight
dude you watch one video on this channel
and and and then you will you will
systematically watch every video on that
channel and then you'll you'll be so
upset that there's not more you'll start
moving on to videos that are called jcs
inspired
all right that's that's not viewing for
the next few days and yeah
but the jcs inspired ones are are never
anywhere near as good as the the real
mccoy jcs criminal psychology
it's funny yeah i love those shows too
but i remember like when i first the
first day of criminology when i was 18
years old starting university we're
sitting in class and the professor at
the time was asking you know what kind
of shows do you all watch
they're going around the classroom and
basically everybody the time csi was the
big thing no like csi csi csi miami
vegas
timbuktu whatever the latest one was and
it definitely got to me was like my
favorite show you know it was a murder
what would you mean
the greatest serial killer of all time
this woman moves from town to town
actually somebody and she's there to
help solve the case then she moves to
the next turn that she kills again
jessica fletcher great serial killer of
all time yeah dude that's fantastic
angela lansbury it really is
dude now that would be a fun
uh
a fun new series where where uh a remake
of murder she wrote where she's the
killer and she pins it on someone
you know and i was definitely serious
what i said i was like come on time to
take there's always a killer
it's fantastic dude
wow that'd be that'd be great yeah
can i ask you about uh i i read on on
wikipedia that you had kovid
is that okay to talk about did you have
a bad bout of it or was it not so well i
i got very fortunate when it came to the
symptoms i lost my sense of smell uh
taste and
was just a little fatigued for a couple
of days but um i mean i didn't smell my
cat's bathroom and i've ate healthy the
whole time because you know pizza tastes
like dried chicken but i'm very like
fortunate again when it comes to wwe
like our covered protocol we're always
following the high standard of testing
and i got tested on the thursday i
wasn't feeling so hot so they said we're
going to test you again on the sunday
before you come to tv we tested me again
on the sunday it came up positive and
thank goodness we did and do that
testing and we're always been so strict
when it comes to the covet testing
because i came up positive if i went
into work on the monday i could have
passed it to someone else i could have
passed it to an at-risk family member so
i feel very grateful you know i have the
high standard of testing we did
throughout this entire day they could do
to this day because we got it i stayed
at home and the wife and i quarantined
and i was able to film my interviews
from home so i was going into a big
match with uh wrestling goldberg at the
time it's huge in the 90s still big
these days i used to watch him as a kid
so i wanted to keep this storyline alive
so i was filming interviews from my gym
at home and my phone like i was the
cameraman the director of the writer and
i would send them in and they were
showing up on monday night raw if you
told like 10 year old me hey one day
you're going to be sitting at home
filming yourself because you're fighting
goldberg in a couple of weeks blowing my
mind it still blows my mind as an adult
yeah
dude that's that's fantastic man i would
have imagined the the kid in you how
stoked was he when you fought the
undertaker
even though you lost still what an honor
yeah
yeah unbelievable like i
fought him when i was 24 i was on an
undefeated streak as they've been
somebody's chosen one we talked about
earlier and the undertaker finally
defeated me and the smackdown before
wrestlemania where he retired sean
michaels so that was his big final match
going into wrestlemania to retire sean
michaels my first loss again though when
i look back at it when i talk about
looking like you look the part he was
such a man like a grown ass man and i
looked like such a boy at the time like
shaving face i weighed about 30 pounds
lighter such a mismatch then i fought
him again in 2019 myself and shane
mcmahon fought the undertaker and roman
reigns in a tag match and i deliberately
asked for a moment where we went face to
face and taker was cool with it
thankfully and when we went face to face
now i looked the part and we got to
trade blows and it was a really fun
match to get back in there with him and
i traveled the world with him as a kid
he was technically my mentor when
someone put him in charge of me as a kid
he only listened to the undertaker so
having a lot of good times with the
undertaker learning over the years just
a genius when it comes to wrestling
man that's epic
um
what about like what other like
mind-boggling
matches did you have did you ever have
like stone cold or
um not a match with he retired and years
ago but i got the opportunity to be on
his um chat show if you like stone cold
the broken skull sessions where they
flew me out to his home when he was
living in l.a at the time we'd never
really chatted beyond hello sir i'm drew
stone cold of course
that was an extent of our relationship
prior to this but i flew to l.a i got
the chance to sit with them it was
supposed to be about two hours for this
special where we're gonna show and we
ended up talking for about eight
straight hours it got to the point where
they had to drag me away from him to get
the flight back from the west coast to
the east coast because i had an
appearance early morning the next day
but he's so smart and passionate about
wrestling and so am i we just connected
right away and we just to this day we
still talk on the phone he's an
incredible best man he's the best like i
i was on his um
his uh tv series with uh oh yeah
i just i fell in love with that guy man
we had him on here as well
yeah he's awesome and it's just that
character like stone cold again like me
being myself finally making that
connection with the fans that's just the
same guy just the volume turned up just
slightly and as we got him over not just
over like the most popular superstar of
all time
he's epic um have you entertained any
ideas about mma or
any like real serious
never
once ever crossed my mind
i enjoy the i do i like watching
occasionally especially the big matches
and i enjoy the training i enjoy like
rolling around
jiu jitsu i love boxing training i hate
keeping my hands up i always get popped
in the face my hands are always dropping
but i enjoy the training i enjoy
watching but it's not something i've
heard a passion for briefly i wanted to
box when i was about 10 when i watched
rocky for the first time my mom was like
no way you're too pretty you're not
boxing go and play hey like soccer like
football that's how you're playing right
now she wouldn't let me box i'm glad she
didn't so my nose is kind of still
straight it's only been broken about
three times instead of 20 times or
whatever but uh yeah yeah never even
entertained the thought yeah good man me
either but god i don't miss a fight dude
i love that ufc stuff
yeah that's fine real fun to watch a lot
of our guys you know trained extensively
in it and we've had a lot of people that
wrestled at the olympic level and i
watched some of them backstage rolling
around together it's just incredible to
watch the technique that you want to get
in absolutely not i've wrestled
professionally since i was 15. i'm good
with that i'm a strictly professional
wrestler yeah i mean
it's it's scary dude but then again i
think that that the tall
wrestling takes on
on one's body
is pretty comparable to that of ufc and
maybe even
more so
yeah it's a schedule like the we're 52
weeks a year no reruns no off seasons
you're making
three towns every weekend non-televised
and then a televised show just the
constant car rides flights they're the
worst in my opinion and then the matches
the constant bumps each fall is
comparable to a small car wreck you just
constantly doing it repeat repeat repeat
repeat every single week you're just
building up injuries over time i said
like boxing with the big gloves and just
instead of ufc getting knocked out quick
you're just slowly doing that damage
um and that's why it's important like i
talked about staying healthy keeping
stretching drinking my big gallon of
water here and taking my supplements to
stay as healthy as possible you drink
you drink a gallon of water a day
yeah i should drink more like being like
270 i probably should drink more but i
try and drink at least a gallon
man that's crazy
all right dude well i i wonder like to
do it i've got one last question
actually
if i could yeah i i read something about
like when you were a kid
you read some conspiracy book and so you
got really yeah i'm surprised you never
brought this up before well and then and
then it said you you reached out to the
fbi for some information through the
freedom of information act and
a few sources said and the fbi actually
sent you some some papers or an envelope
or something but nobody said what was in
it like what they told you
what do you know drew
what was it about what was the case
well they sent everything no like there
was a sample letter in a magazine called
the x factor magazine i used to get when
i was a kid literally 10 11 years old it
was conspiracy theories ghosts ufos
strange bugs read about the ebola virus
when i was like 10. i was a weird kid i
also loved dressing up for wrestling
really good kids
and i filled in this sample letter and
you know under the freedom of
information act you just followed a word
for word and add in the document she
wanted i believe i requested roswell
project blue book a few ufo related
things sent it away and sure enough a
few weeks later used my pocket money to
send it away came back home from school
and my dad was waiting for me and i was
like dad why are you home you're never
home until like 6 7 p.m this is like
four in the afternoon when i got home
from school and he just said this big
dossier in his lap it's a dream why are
the fbi in america
sending you documents oh because i asked
for them daddy they'll never forget he
kept saying in america why are the
federal bureau of investigation in
america sending these documents oh it's
fine and you know it's under the freedom
of information act it's perfectly legal
and i paid for it you know with my
pocket money whatever it's my business
it's true like i believe it was a live
enjoy you're 11 years old just go
outside and play football or something
took my documents off from nonetheless
set them in my cupboard went and played
for a while and came back looked at them
and they blacked out all the important
stuff i used a magnifying glass whatever
i could to try and find them but yeah
that was pretty fun and my dad still
talked to that story to this day
you're lucky you were so big as a kid
you're gonna get so beat up
i feel like that leads to a follow-up
question
because now all of these like the
united states government the pentagon
like are actually coming out and saying
no ufos are real
and nobody's willing to always pay
attention i'm looking around
it's like wait a second they're like i
mean if you if you told like 10 or 11
year old drew
that
like the the united states government is
going to come out and acknowledge the
ufos are completely real
and nobody's going to give a [ __ ]
it'll blow my mind i mean that's the
thing i realized when i was like again
11 years old whatever it was like all
these conspiracy theories you know
they're not all true but with the smoke
there's fire realistically if i find
anything out they're probably gonna make
me disappear so i should focus on this
wrestling thing so that's when i started
focusing on the wrestling thing and
thankfully it worked out but yeah we're
now in 2020 2021 now they've been
releasing these videos and with
everything going on in the world just
flying under the radar yeah my mind is
blowing like pilots literally saying we
can't do that
yeah it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
well dude thank you so much for doing
this man it's really uh it's really rad
and um for being so open dude obviously
your book's gonna be epic so let's
remind everybody to get on there and buy
the a chosen destiny drew mcintyre my
story dude and uh did you like do you
have a preference like go and buy it in
retail or buy it on amazon
yeah i mean if you just look on the
internet as i say it's everywhere and
very fortunate it was so widely
distributed and if you like it just
please give me your feedback on social
media i especially enjoy the ones where
you know people are able to get help
through something they read in my book
i've read so many of them and i
appreciate every single one so hit me
with that feedback and guys thanks for
having me on today this was genuinely
fun like i'm always so serious about our
viewers but you get the chance just to
sit and chat yeah be so relaxed it's a
lot of fun and we're in your area if we
got a show there make sure you hit us up
we're getting to the show and i promise
you won't get knocked out if you're on
the show
now i know we're going to be close to
nashville uh
i have a show coming up in chattanooga
tennessee
oh really let us know when if it's a day
that i'm not working my wife and i will
definitely be there i'll bring sheamus
along to other wwe so we're feeding them
tv right now but we'll make peace for
that one night
that's epic man
and uh
on social media what's your handle
um i'm gonna get this right
it's one with a tick at d mcintyre wwe
on twitter and instagram and if anybody
messages anyone out there telling them
you're me and asking for money or that
you're gonna start a relationship and it
doesn't have the tick please people it's
not me stop sending these people yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna follow you right now
on uh
uh d mcintyre on instagram um
wwe and uh okay good
good i'm gonna follow you on there right
now as should everybody else and uh dude
thank you again brother
so i appreciate you both and we'll see
you all in the
future about that huh just gotta respect
that guy man
and um what can i say dude
big big things happening man i i have
been
on a theater tour over here folks i mean
if you don't know about my bucket list
tour
find out okay
because it is popping down
and as always thank you guys for
sticking around to the very end i
genuinely appreciate you
and i love you
yeah dude